[Music]
hey y'all here we are again with one of
our
matinee shows this one was actually
sort of indirectly i guess uh sent to us
by a uk fan
dermot yeah who sent me the amazon uh
gift card to buy it with
and i really can't believe that we
haven't done this [ __ ] movie because
it's only one of the best movies ever
made come on now
yeah i got the 40 uh the 45th
anniversary blu-ray
4k edition with the entire little
booklet and all that [ __ ] has that cool
cover oh yeah and it's also kind of
scary because sharks are [ __ ]
terrifying yeah
um this movie was
probably the original blockbuster oh it
was
yeah i mean it started the whole
phenomenon yeah not only
i you know what prior to uh this coming
out
in the summer of 1975 i think that
summer
was not seen as blockbuster season at
all which is funny because everybody
just thinks of it like oh that's when
the big tentpole movies come out in the
summertime
not before jaws came out they came out
in the winter time after that
i remember it when it came out as a kid
i was living in long beach california at
the time
and when jaws came out i was six years
old everybody was talking about it
the [ __ ] theme saw the dude dude
and all that and everybody older than me
was talking about it
i wasn't able to see it they didn't take
me to see it but my parents saw it
i saw it later okay yeah but i remember
when it came out and what a phenomenon
it was
and that was the beginning of of the
hollywood
that we know if you're alive it was that
time
oh yeah everything got everything went
steven spielberg george lucas and these
guys started off as like it almost like
indie filmmakers
big studios didn't make films like this
they just come out of
making things like westerns and cop type
movies
and private eye type movies you know
like bullet and all that they were okay
for the time and
but this was the new hollywood that
that i grew up with later on it
was it was announced with jaws that
changed the game
um those days are over but i was i was
happy to grow up during this era
because we got some of the best movies
from new dudes you know tour raider one
predator all that kind of stuff
it was came from this movie yeah this is
the movie that changed the game
that allowed all those other franchises
to appear
and it's really crazy because
considering the backstory of how jaws
got made
one it's amazing that it came out being
one of the best movies ever because the
whole production was
uh went way over budget way over time um
you know that it was just plagued with
problems like the whole entire time they
were making it which usually spells
disaster but for some reason
this one was just [ __ ] magic yeah and
and
another thing i was going to say too was
that steven spielberg had made
a couple movies before this i believe
the one he made before this was
sugarland express but he wasn't
um a big name no you know what i mean
not at all and he actually he wasn't
even the first choice to direct this
yeah when lucas came out with star wars
he wasn't a big name either yeah
it was these were brand new guys they
had an
indie film background they were making
movies
that the old studios of that era would
have bettered against
they'd be like a movie about a shark
that'll never make money
although interestingly the the book you
know the peter benchley book
i think that the rights to it were
optioned by a dude at disney
uh without corporate approval because he
loved
the book actually hadn't been published
yet but he got like a galley of it and
he's like oh my god that would make a
great [ __ ] movie so he went ahead and
paid for the rights and then he got
fired
but then he took the rights like
somewhere else and they're the ones that
ended up making it
well new guys knew that the old student
the ways of the old studios were
coming to an end you just couldn't live
off of making damn westerns
and cop movies you had to [ __ ] make
interesting new movies for a new
generation
yeah and it's the first one really and
the thing is like a lot of people were
making interesting movies in the 60s and
70s i feel like too in the 60s and 70s
you got more of
like the auteur type of movies where it
was just like one director's vision and
a lot of them were kind of
you know subversive or whatever so you
had a lot of that this one was kind of
your first
big i guess like a crowd-pleasing movie
that everybody could see but there was
also a really really quality flick yeah
they were they were aimed at the
mainstream
yeah yeah and but they were one man's
vision
they weren't compromising but it was
still a movie for everybody yeah
the the style back then
is the winning style if you ask me if
you compare it to today
they would try to do something like well
the way they interpret the situation is
very different
they would say we have this story and we
got to make this movie for everybody
so let's go ahead and kind of change and
make the the
the entire cast totally diverse and
it'll be for everybody
that's not how you do it you tell the
story from a point of view
of a couple people and then the story
itself becomes for everybody
the cast doesn't have to be that diverse
the story has to be relatable to
everybody here's an example
when i see us when i see when i want to
see a samurai movie
i want to see japanese people in it i
want that samurai movie to come from
japan
i don't even want it to be in english
all right there's no diversity there in
that crowd
but that story is for everybody you know
what i mean
well it's in i yeah it's like it's stuff
that everybody can relate to
everybody can relate to but i'm seeing
i'm being told this story
through the eyes of japanese people
that's why that's why i'm watching it
yeah you know what i mean and i think
hollywood's lost its way they don't
really understand that anymore in the
modern era
but they understood it back in the 70s
and the 80s
and in the end parts of the 90s just
tell a damn story if it's a good story
everybody will like it
yeah and honestly i don't think i've
ever met a single
[ __ ] on this earth that does not
like jaws how could you not like
jaws yeah it's a great [ __ ] movie
yeah
it was it's everything it's scary it's
funny it's got like great characters
it's got great special effects it's just
it's a fantastic
everything about it is good yeah and
everything about it makes sense it's
new englanders different coming from
different classes one of them
one of them is a law enforcement the
other one is a [ __ ] salty ass
[ __ ] sea veteran and the other one is
a
younger up-and-coming scientist and
they're all trying to catch this big
damn shark
yeah and i mean you can't really get any
better than that right it's like a
monster movie but it's like an elevated
monster yeah and they're up they're up
in new england and they're the kind of
guys that you would meet in new england
you know doing this so it all just kind
of made sense
yeah it feels very authentic i mean i
kind of want to say too that i didn't
even realize this until i was watching a
couple of
you know uh you know film students or
film historians like breaking down jaws
and they said you know not only was jaws
kind of the start of the summer
blockbuster phenomenon
uh i should note too that it was also
the start of the
wide release for a big tent tentpole
movie because prior
to that they didn't really do that
everything was kind of a slow release
like they would release things in big
cities and then if it did well they
would kind of expand it
whereas this one they you know they
wanted to open it everywhere like at the
same time which was kind of
unprecedented at that time
so this one was the first one to do a
lot of things that people take for
granted nowadays
but something that i didn't realize was
that you know how
you know your standard popular uh you
know mainstream movies have your three
act structure which
that's not even i mean books have that
everything has that because it works you
know what i mean that formula works
but this movie i mean normally a movie
would be like the the formulaic three
act structure it's usually like first
act is 25
of the movie second act is 50 of the
movie and then
the you know the the climax of whatever
and the and the dynamo or whatever
that's that's another 25
what jaws does is they do the first act
takes half of the movie
where they're establishing the
characters yes there are some shark
attacks but they don't show the shark
until about an hour in which i think was
a genius move even though it wasn't
completely
uh done on purpose um but then it's like
then the second act is 25
and then the third act is 25 with in the
whole thing with the scene
where um where uh quint is talking about
the uss indianapolis and all the people
getting eaten by sharks
that's almost kind of like th that's
almost toward the end of the movie
you know what i mean that that's a
that's a masterpiece
move to put that character as a survivor
of the indianapolis yeah
because if you guys don't know what that
was the indianapolis was on a secret
mission to
to deliver the atomic bomb out to an
atoll that we'd take and they were going
to load that onto the
enola gay bomb japan with it
well they delivered the bomb but later
got got sucked they got torpedoed and
like 1100 dudes went in the water
and because they were on a secret
mission
they the u.s navy pretended like they
didn't know about it because they didn't
want anybody to know
that that ship was out there so they let
all those dudes just sit in the water
and be eaten for about a week
i think it's five days yeah they were
found all floating out in the water by
accident by a plane a seaplane
who did give it aid to them but they
were just going to be sacrificed well
they were started 1100 dudes
and uh five days later only 300 left
they had all been eaten by sharks
yep all right that's true true story
absolutely true story
[Laughter]
so this guy who's this salty
[ __ ] who acts like a real dick
you're like man what what is this dude
what is it about this dude that he makes
him so high and mighty well he did have
a grudge against the sharks and he was
hardcore he was a hardcore survivor back
when he was young
of the indianapolis so that was kind of
his street cred you don't find out
towards the end like
and and you know and even even the
richard dreyfus character who had ana
was jealous of him animosity was like oh
oh damn you survived that
and that was his jacket that was his
second street cred
dude that he was a survivor of that so
that kata
gave him his his credibility
but he was also a captain ahab he went
down fighting that shark
yeah and plus he made some really stupid
rash decisions
and stupid mistakes yeah well the best
thing about this and i
was actually thinking this when we were
re-watching the movie again and i was
glad to see that a couple other
reviewers pointed this out as well
one of the best things about this movie
is
the three characters uh you know of
quint and brody and hooper
who are very much like the the trio at
the middle of like star trek
uh where each of them has something to
bring to the table but they're all
vastly different and so throughout the
whole movie you're getting this kind of
conflict
particularly between hooper who is
younger he comes from money
um and he's like more scientist based uh
even though he's
he knows his [ __ ] like he's been out in
ships he knows everything about sharks
and everything like that
but yeah he's a diver and stuff so he's
not like some soft like mama's boy
weaponry yeah but he but he's kind of
like represents the new thing like with
all this new
technology whereas quint is much more
like the old-fashioned
i mean he they establish early on that
he's really good at what he does too
because his like
shack is all full of like you know shark
teeth and like shark that he's caught
everybody in town knows who he is he has
a reputation
but he kind of feels like well you know
all this new stuff it's almost kind of
like cheating or whatever
so him and hooper like butt heads a lot
because they kind of feel like
both of them feel like the other one
doesn't know what they're doing
well there's class there there's that
there's also social class happening here
yeah
again quint is working man
self-made he came up through a system of
military service and then
maritime apprenticeship and actually
doing things
in the real world the old school way on
these ships
you know what i mean he was a commercial
seaman
you don't really go to schools per se
for that you don't go to universities
for that you go to basically little
trade schools and training programs
and you serve under the command of
[ __ ] captains all right so it's
it's hard earned learn as you go taught
through mentorship and apprenticeship
and you got the other guy who did it
through a university system
and the more highbrow version of it so
you got
kind of like intellectual class versus
working class
they got on the same mission they both
had their own strengths and weaknesses
which you know it kind of played out and
then brody's law enforcement he's kind
of like
the the reasonable guy in the middle and
he's kind of like the common sense dude
but he's also like the guy that doesn't
have any experience with this guy
right yeah he's the uh he kind of the
stand-in for the every man yeah
like he's not a boat guy he doesn't like
the water yeah um
you know he's he just wants to go
because he wants to keep his family
safe and so he you know even though he's
terrified even though he doesn't really
know anything
about what they're doing he volunteers
he's like you know i'm going to go with
you because i want to help kill this
shark
look the movie's about a damn shark
catching a damn shark there's not a
whole lot there
the movie is [ __ ] character driven
suspense driven it's these three dudes
trying to catch this monster it's great
it's a masterpiece
i mean it really is it's honestly one of
the best movies i've ever made he didn't
have great acting and great characters
the movie would have been forgotten
you see this movie to see these
characters that's what that's what well
like i said it's almost like the guy
like you know spock kirk and bones on
star trek it's the same kind of dynamic
and i love the scene where they're all
getting drunk together in the cabin you
know like where
like prior to him giving the uss
indianapolis speech which is one of the
most famous yeah they're there
monologues comparing scars and stuff but
that was the first time that they all
came together
as a team like prior to that they've
kind of been butting heads like i said
hooper and quinn are kind of like you
know new guy versus old guys there's a
pissing contest and then and then yeah
and brody was kind of like because he
just didn't know anything about anything
and so they just thought he was kind of
a nuisance because it's like what are
you even doing here but i mean you know
not like that but it was kind of
he didn't know anything about ships he
didn't know what he said for the
audience
yeah so um but that was kind of the
first time that they all kind of came
together and we're all on the same team
and so they all had like such a great
arc i mean particularly brody
who started out you know because they
they established this like pretty uh
elegantly in the movie that him and his
family have moved to this town
to amity from new york city and so he
doesn't really know anything about the
water he doesn't know anything about
this community
uh the community kind of looks at him a
little bit askance because he's not from
there he's like an outsider
and they don't really i like that they
don't hammer that home
but it's just it's just little subtle
things
you know what i mean like no one's
hostile toward him outright but you can
tell that they
that you know they think that he's not
one of them
you know the same thing because there's
even a couple things saying you know if
you didn't grow up here then you're
never gonna be accepted
because you're still just like an
outsider yeah and i just really like the
way they
you know put all these characters
together and um
i should say too like i said the novel
by peter benchley
which you know that they read before it
was even published were like yeah we're
gonna make this into a movie
i read the book and it's funny because
somebody else uh
in the youtube comments mentioned this
as well that they saw the movie first
and then they read the book
and they're like you know the movie is
like so much better than the book which
is i mean the book is good
but this is another example where i
think the movie is much better because
i will say that in the book there's a
subplot
that brody's wife um and hooper have an
affair
which i think that was probably not good
like
that was better to leave that out
because you know yes it would have
caused more conflict between the two
guys and whatever
but i don't think that's really needed
because there was enough conflict there
was enough like
you know different personalities and i
kind of liked
that hooper and um and brody
were they weren't really at loggerheads
they were they were friends they had the
same their personalities were very
different but they had the same
mission so i liked that those two were
kind of like backing each other up and
then
quint was kind of like the you know the
one that was causing
uh rancor like within the trio brody
being
being i guess chief of police of the
damn island
he's he was in a neutral position how
are we going to solve this problem with
this shark eating everybody
yeah the mayor doesn't want the place
was he in the mayor that didn't want to
shut it down
and his kids were out there too you know
in the water and then
three people had to get eaten before the
mayor would finally be like oh yeah
maybe we should yeah
brody's kind of like in in in this
middle position where he's trying to
make the
make the best decision eventually he's
like let's hire that dude
yeah that clint guy what's with quinn
yeah
let's hire let's hire quint to go um get
that shark
and uh but he also had aligned with
hooper too about cutting the other shark
open
and doing it you know and and accepting
the fact that
the shark that they caught is not the
not the jaws shark
that that's a much smaller shark you
know the bite radius wasn't right
you know hooper didn't really want to
accept that he wanted it to be that
shark but then he started like yeah it
probably isn't that shark
you know well hooper that's really where
their friendship kind of yeah
is when he when he they were backing one
another up yeah where he
was when he figured yeah hooper's
probably right that's not the same shark
he was pretty convinced that it wasn't
the same shark i mean he would he wanted
to go cut it open just to make sure but
he was pretty sure when he measured the
mouth
but the thing about it and like i said
that's where a lot of the conflict comes
from too
because brody like i said being the
chief of police but also being not from
there and so a little bit of an outsider
is kind of coming at it from you know
the mayor and all the other city
officials
all they really care about is oh it's
fourth of july weekend all these this is
our
you know towns kind of claim to fame
everybody's gonna come here and spend
money we need the tourist dollars
so we just can't close the beaches off
and all these business owners and [ __ ]
are going to lose money so that was
pretty much their only concern so when
you know chrissy who was the first
victim uh you know
you see her at the very beginning like
skinny dipping and she gets pulled under
and eaten and then they find her the
next day
and then that little kid gets eaten and
then there's like that other boat with
that great jump scare where that head
like pops out of the bottom of the
fishing boat which is
probably one of the best jump scares
ever but it's like once it gets to that
point and once it gets to the point
where the shark actually comes in and
attacks
when all these people are at the beach
and the mayor realizes hey
my kids were at the beach too and that
could have been my kid then finally
finally
after three or four people i got chewed
up
he finally decides okay we're gonna do
it let's hire quint let's do something
about it
but it takes that long for him to
because like i said all they cared about
was the profit motive and the
the fact too that they that they were so
quick the mayor was so quick to be like
that one shark that got caught
be like oh yeah that's gotta be it let's
you know just forget all about it and so
we can open the beaches up
because you know sharks caught nothing
to see here um
you know it by offering the by offering
the three thousand dollars which because
it was three thousand dollars at first
and then all those people idiots like
came from out of town because they heard
about this three thousand dollars
so then they caused even more chaos and
even more people being in the water
because all these people were trying to
like go out there and catch the shark
and get the three thousand dollars and
none of them knew what they were doing
so probably they should have just hired
quint to start with but you know what
stands out to me about the movie is a
fantastic acting
there isn't any bad acting in the movie
um
roy he knocks it out of the park playing
the cop
um the dude that played quint
robert shaw robert shaw just steals the
show
all right he's like okay he just steals
that
i don't know i don't know if he did any
other movies this is the only time i've
seen that guy
you know yeah he was in some other
videos but yeah i'll tell you what man
that
that character and hit in the way he did
that character just [ __ ] takes the
cake
and uh dreyfus dreyfus is [ __ ] great
in this movie
i mean up there with uh close encounters
you know
yeah it's like it's a really different
character but i really really like
i always liked dreyfus yeah i did too
he's kind of like the smart little guy
yeah that's you know and every man he's
kind of he kind of
he does those kind of roles but um no
just [ __ ] this is movie's a
masterpiece it aged really really well
shark even looks really good now when it
eats quit
you can tell it's not a real shark but
it didn't take me out of the movie
it didn't take me but it was in the
water i was like was that a real shark
it wasn't it was something towed by
another boat when it goes by that it
looked like a real
damn shark a huge huge shark but it was
just
some kind of model that they were towing
with another boat yeah i think they had
three different models
of the shark which they called bruce
which most people know
they had one uh that was kind of like
full that was like one side that went
back and forth
and then they had another one that was
kind of like from the other side that
went back and forth and then they had
one that they could pull like from
underwater
the one that you could see from the top
and yeah shot when it was yeah that was
like pulled on a tow line
i could tell but it looked real but i've
seen the only way they could have done
that is it was like a submersible that
they were towing
yeah i thought it looked like a real
shark although i couldn't see
the back one third of the damn shark did
it have a tail um
because it might not have just the front
in the middle it might not have because
i think some of them weren't entire
sharks
it didn't look like an entire shark but
it convinced me that there was a shark
maybe it thought that maybe
just the back of it was in shadow yeah
you know what i mean but
i was like it was definitely a real
object yeah i mean it definitely looked
well it definitely looked a hell of a
lot better than cgi
oh yeah i'll tell you that right now um
you told me it was a real shark i would
go oh okay
now the shots that were done underwater
those were real sharks
yeah and those were actually filmed by a
husband and wife diving team i can't
remember what their names are
but they filmed those off of australia
now this the scene where the shark
attacks the cage
yeah that looked real it was uh what
ended up
and that was totally accidental but what
ended up happening
in the book and i think in the original
uh screenplay of the movie
uh hooper actually does get eaten like
from out of that cage right
but then they decided what they were
going to do because they got
footage in australia of an empty cage
that was down in the uh in the water and
a shark just
going [ __ ] ham on it and like killing
the [ __ ] thing
they're like oh man we got to put that
in the movie yeah because that's so so
good i mean it looked great
but they're like but if we do that then
he's attacking an empty cage so at that
point we have to like let richard try
this
we have to let him get out of the cage
so hooper was originally supposed to die
like brody was supposed to be the only
one that lived i think it's good though
that he
he lived i think it was too i think that
had been a bummer it was a bummer that
quinn died
but like i said he was he had a captain
ahab moment
he had to die he smashed the radio yeah
he blew the engine even though you know
the other guys were saying hey
you know the engine can't take it and
all this other kind of [ __ ] because the
shark had been like [ __ ] the boat up
yeah they got salt water in the fuel it
burned up the [ __ ] injectors too
so he just got so um you know he was
just so overwhelmed by his
mission to get this [ __ ] shark and
like get revenge on this [ __ ] shark
that he just made a bunch of stupid
decisions yeah we put other people's
life at risk
yeah and he had to go down like a
captain ahead and and
him with the annapolis story made sense
because now it was personal to him
yeah that his vengeance against these
sharks was personal
so it made sense yeah it made sense that
he that
he was pissed and wasn't going to give
up and wasn't going to let anybody stand
in his way
and it also made sense that he had to
die yeah by this shark
yeah because he could have got them all
killed yeah now as it was gobbled
him up i think they maybe should have
included something where he was at least
able to
stab it or hit it i thought he did hit
it with the machete he hit it
did he okay yeah i thought he wounded it
right okay well then then okay i didn't
remember because he didn't decide like
when he when he comes like before
uh before brody like shoots it like
smile you son of a [ __ ] or whatever
and then they show it like under the
water isn't it like it has like a cut
like on the side of the mouth or
something like that
with it he should have done it maybe i
did see him do that but yeah i thought
he had the machete or he had because he
grabbed the machete
yeah off the wall and i'm pretty sure
yeah well and he did and i mean he was
like screaming his head off
and he got his he got like bit in half
just like they're just like
just like the guy that uh that bubbled
up bobbed up at
on the uss indianapolis in the story
that he told so it's like
everything about this is i mean this is
one of the best made
movies and i like it because the
storytelling
is so economical i kind of feel like
a lot of movies and just from any era
really
um that you know movies that are not all
that great
i think a mistake that a lot of people
made is they over explain things
they forget that it's a visual medium
that they can just show things instead
of like
telling things through dialogue or
exposition or whatever which is very
clunky
this one really just has it's it's very
very economical in the way that it sets
up the characters
um you know they say a couple of things
that can you know hint about their past
and stuff
but mostly it's kind of just like in
their body language the way they you
know
what stuff that's in the background just
you know stuff like that
and i just feel like that's the best way
to go because you really get a sense of
them
without having someone having to tell
you the whole shark
combat phase of the movie
the whole shark combat phase of the
movie is kind of like something out of
fury road
they're not telling they're showing yeah
running around from one side of the boat
to the next and then
tell each other help you know you get
this cut that line you know what i mean
i'm gonna put another barrel in him it's
like like a
fury road yeah it's very action oriented
there's not a lot of i mean there's
dialogue in it but it's not
they're just talking about the shark
they're just talking about the shark
like just like it would really be
like if you were there you don't have
time to like dick around yeah or talk
about talk about your feelings or
anything like that it's like
we're getting attacked by a [ __ ]
25-foot shark that's gonna
talk about their feelings you haven't
been watching today
can we say too that uh it we would be
very remiss in talking about [ __ ]
jaws for christ's sake without talking
about that [ __ ] score
yeah john williams pretty good it was
good and honestly uh he went on to work
with steven spielberg for almost all of
his movies subsequently i think
but even steven spielberg himself said
that uh
this movie wouldn't have worked without
that score and he's like the he's like
seriously 50
of the success of this movie is because
of that [ __ ] music yeah and i think
that it's
it's really well done because the
and i think this helps out a lot too
with like you know kind of building up
the suspense and everything and like i
said
i think they were going to show the
shark more a little bit
but obviously they had a lot of trouble
with the shark but didn't work and all
this other kind of stuff
so they kind of kept it to a minimum
which famously ended up working in the
movie's favor
because now everything is just
suggestion
like you know the first scene where
chrissy gets pulled under the water you
don't see anything you just see her get
pulled down you know it's a shark
because obviously you've seen the poster
um but the rest of stuff is just all
suggestion like you see kind of
when the kid gets eaten um you know you
just kind of see a fin and a tail and
the kid kind of flopping over
and then you see like his bloody float
like come like wash up on the beach
and it's just they don't really show the
shark until later on
and so it's almost kind of like that
theme song
like stands in for the shark so you know
the sharks there
because you can hear it yeah you know
what i mean one of the things that was
odd about the movie though that i
noticed while i was watching it
is that most a lot of it took place on a
beach
filled with people and [ __ ] bathing
suits and bikinis
they even had a scene where a check
strip runs gets drunk
runs strips all her clothes off and then
goes skinny dip and
you don't really see anything but and
all this is going on beaches and skinny
dipping and swimming
nude swimming and [ __ ] and there's
really what's weird about the movies
there's not no real sex appeal to the
movie
you notice that well it's not really
that kind of that kind of a movie now
you would think another movie would at
least shown like
you know what i mean like some nudity
although
spielberg doesn't really do that or they
at least would have shown like some hot
bikini chicks that's
normal hollywood would have done that
this didn't didn't do that
well i think too that he wanted it to
kind of convey the sense of place
because a lot of the people i mean that
is a real beach town it's not called
amity which i can't remember what the
name of it is but that is a real beach
town uh that they filmed that i think
it's on martha's vineyard
and he just wanted so all the extras
were just people from around there
yeah so he just wanted like he wanted
the flavor of the place so he used
everybody from there like and just put
them in the movie so obviously they're
not all gonna look like
[ __ ] super bottles yeah i just
thought it was odd it was out of
character for a hollywood movie there's
usually a little more sex appeal in
there
that's something it didn't really occur
to me i guess yeah um well i saw the
missed opportunities
yeah well maybe he just didn't want it
to be like a schlocky like
monster movie that's what it normally
would have been well i know that
yeah but i think that maybe is what
elevates it too it's that it's
it's kind of like like i said it's an
action adventure movie and also a horror
movie and also a nature
run amok kind of movie but everybody can
watch it because you remember
like the ripoff like piranha had a lot
of such appeal in it so
they're always trying to compensate when
they do do that instead of that they had
a weird thing
that when i was a kid i could remember
it
because i saw it i saw this a couple
years after it came out which i may have
been seven or eight
brody's kid was having all these
emotional reactions to [ __ ]
chasing people on the beach going daddy
daddy or crying and [ __ ]
to try to and he was like an emoticon
he's like the emoji
[Laughter]
and uh that was that was odd i did not
odd really
no it's not odd i mean that's a pretty
common thing and steven spielberg did
that a lot too it's
like kids to [ __ ] well because that
is something
that's something that um that most
people
most people are going to respond to a
child in danger yeah
um that's always going to be scarier
than an adult in danger because he's a
little kid
and the fact that he that steven
spielberg actually had the balls to have
several little kids get [ __ ] eaten in
this movie
is like a pretty [ __ ] hardcore even
though they didn't really
i mean they didn't show but they kind of
showed it and honestly
it's the suggestion of it is almost
worse because it like leaves it to your
imagination well that little kid never
was in any danger in any danger himself
he was reacting to other people
well brodie had two kids he had that
little bitty kid and then he had like
the older the slightly older i'm talking
about
the little bitty kid yeah he was always
on the beach and if a crowd of people
would be running he said dad did it
he's yelling at her other kids somebody
get eaten and he'd go ah
you know i mean the other kid that was
slightly older
the one he was endangered he was in
danger because he was like in the
michael i think that kid's name was and
um and he was actually in the pond
you know on the fourth of july like when
the beach was crowded when that shark
attacked in the pond
so that kid michael saw another guy get
eaten
like right by him so i thought it was an
unusual ploy
i was one of the first times i've really
kind of noticed them doing that
it it did work though yeah well and i
think too
the fact that his kid i mean hit
him having those two little kids and
then being around the water all the time
i think that was one of the things that
you know and the and then michael's
seeing that guy get eaten like
only a few feet away from him and him
going into shock and having to the
hospital and everything
i think that was the main thing that
spurred brody
into getting over his fear and going i'm
gonna go out there and get that [ __ ]
thing because
it could it could have eaten my kid yeah
well i guess spielberg used that also
in close encounters yeah a little kid
sucking talking over yeah
yeah barry and then and then
looking the little kids like hey can we
throw dirt in our window too yeah
it was kind of but they were they were
used more for comedy
yeah yeah although i you know what i've
i've seen jaws like a million times but
i probably haven't seen it
for several years at this point so we
watched it again last night the 45th
anniversary the transfer looks gorgeous
it sounds gorgeous fantastic and i had
forgotten i remembered that there was
funny [ __ ] in this movie but i had
forgotten
some of the funny [ __ ] in this movie one
of my favorite scenes and it's just such
a throwaway
is when they're first on the boat and
quint gets
he has his little can of yingling or
whatever and he chugs it back and then
he crushes the can
and then he's like looking at hooper and
then hooper lick looks back at him all
serious and he's got like some coffee
and a
styrofoam cup and he drinks it just like
crushes
i it love that it's just like and i like
it's just like little [ __ ] like that
i think most of the funniest [ __ ] is
like richard dreyfuss honestly yeah
he's just such a naturally funny guy
it's like not even jokes or anything
like that he's just a funny dude he's
real likable
he plays real likeable characters yeah
that's i think that's what it is and
like i said i think the trio of them
you know being together being so
different but then kind of teaming up
like for this common goal
i think is one of the things that makes
this a classic and i mean
all the characters are likable quint is
like he's still likeable
even though at first he kind of comes
across like a dick because
he's this this salty old nobody knows he
was a dick knows what they're doing
except for me
and blah blah blah and singing about
bow-legged women and all that yeah
hold on was that okay i had to analyze
that
well that first scene when they go to
higher quint and his [ __ ] and his
[ __ ] shack or whatever
or his cabin it's not a shack and it's
like has shark teeth everywhere
and he has this uh he gives brody and
hooper some of his i could assume
it's moonshine and he's like here i made
that or whatever and then
he drinks it he's like of course and
then he passes by hooper and he's like
don't drink this
it's just like little [ __ ] like that he
wasn't acting like he was better than
them he was just
he was he was just letting them know
that they were [ __ ] compared to him
well yeah because he i mean and i mean
he was a tough [ __ ] he says let
me see your hands
it's a soft hand city hand he's like you
can't come with me
all that [ __ ] made sense from his point
of view remember yeah remember all the
semen that he
tricked and tried to drive him on the
damn rocks yeah and they were out there
trying to
so the local competition he was up
against when it came to sea captains
they sucked compared to him there was a
bunch of other morons
throwing dynamite in the water like oh
yeah trying to get the [ __ ]
so he was just laughing at them yeah so
he was better than every he was the best
sea captain on the on on the island
he had a real history of service and
sacrifice on the sea
you know he was hardcore all right
nobody on the island could compare to
him
how's one of these little city boys came
from a university with soft hands you
know
and all this money how is he going to
compare to his toughness
yeah and so he was right you know what i
mean he's trying to establish dominance
you can't come with me you won't survive
the mission
but then finally it's okay but you're
starting it so you can come well that's
why i liked that one scene toward the
end where
uh you know quint is kind of like he
he's actually never i mean the shark is
like much much larger
uh than anyone that he's had to deal
with before and it's actually they imply
that it's a little bit smarter too
because it does a lot of crazy [ __ ]
so he finally after he kind of flips out
he destroys the radio he kind of [ __ ]
up the boat
and then finally he gets to a point
where he can say to hooper
hey like what's this equipment dude
let's use this yeah so he is a big
enough man
yeah yeah he's a big enough man to admit
hey my methods aren't working
so let's try your [ __ ] out so they've
established high ticks
yeah so they've established like mutual
respect between one another which like i
said i think that was a really really
great yeah
um so all the character arcs are like
really great in this and how they you
know they they kind of forged this
unlikely friendship
yeah uh to you know to kill this [ __ ]
monster and what what what
uh what he had was is he had this
hypodermic syringe on the end of a down
pole with this drug that
there's evidently enough to kill the
shark and uh
he's like can you get that needle
through his skin
i don't know maybe in his mouth
so you know yeah he was gonna go
with the high-tech root they're gonna
get him into a cage
let the shark bite the cage and he was
gonna stab a shark in the mouth with
that drug which that's pretty ballsy
because you wouldn't get my ass
well i think that's what they were
trying to tell you yeah is that
um that that little dude had the balls
yeah to get in that flimsy aluminum
cage and basically sacrifice himself
he could have made it no yeah and i
think he kind of knew i think he knew
that to sacrifice himself
to save the rest of the crew so you know
respected him he's like okay yeah he he
totally like got that he was you know
just as good they
they were coming at it from a different
thing but they had a common goal and
they were just coming at it from
different ways that's all and so i liked
that they established that kind of yeah
it all worked out and they did it really
subtly like i said you know the
just quent like holding that gun up and
saying yeah what does this do or what
can you do with this or whatever yeah
like accepting you know we're let's try
it your way now
and not making a big deal about it and
clint saw the weakness in it
the strength and the weakness yeah the
drug might do it but what about that
needle
yeah can you get that needle through his
skin and the boy was like
i don't think so yeah maybe we'll have
to get him in the mouth
yeah much like i said they had a plan
yeah so i just i don't know i just this
is a great [ __ ] movie
if you've never seen jaws what planet
are you even from
because i feel like well i feel like
it's so
this is one of those movies that's just
so ingrained in
american culture particularly probably
like worldwide because it's like made
a zillion dollars like around the world
and it was a huge hit everywhere
but i kind of feel like this is so
ingrained that even if you haven't seen
it you've kind of seen it
i grew up as a kid even swimming out in
[ __ ] the bayou louisiana
okay with the vague fear of
[Music]
something coming up biting me yeah that
big ass shark
which is not crazy because a shark can
get into the [ __ ] bio
yeah they get it they can go into fresh
water yep
they can't stay in there for long but
long enough long enough to eat you
yeah that's what i figure tiger sharks
do it
yeah yeah and that's the thing it's like
[ __ ] man this movie i mean i was scared
of sharks anyway
because like i said i grew up in daytona
beach right on the atlantic ocean we
went to the beach all the time
and i did see sharks uh not as big as
that one obviously
but i did see them like quite often and
they would just scare the crap out of me
so i wouldn't really go in any deeper
than five high or whatever
so seeing this is like my worst [ __ ]
nightmare like being in the water and
knowing that that [ __ ] is swimming
around right underneath you
looking at your legs like look at those
little wiggly snacks up there i'm going
to [ __ ] grab that [ __ ]
yikes i went um snorkeling
at shaw mill shake that's down in the
gulf of aqaba in egypt
off coast sinai cyanide snorkeling next
to those coral reefs that have fish
following me
some of them pretty big big old sheep's
head and i was always
you could look at that damn reef wall
and be and i was afraid of passing
something like a damn
tunnel that had a dab more a eel in it
yeah because i don't choke either yeah
and then i'd look out
and look out into the ocean had clear
water visibility was really good and it
always had this kind of vague fear that
off in the distance you'd see a big-ass
shark coming out of that blue
you know and there be you'd have to head
for the surface and try to get up on top
of the damn coral reef and you just get
cut up
it's real sharp i mean i think i think
another reason too that this movie
worked so well and why everybody likes
this movie is because that's a very very
primal fear a lot of people have that
fear of just this
being in the water or being somewhere
you can't really see
and all of a sudden this massive like
behemoth yeah coming out of the darkness
that can eat you in the situation i was
in you could see probably about
300 feet which is enough visibility to
see in enough directions
to where you'd have time to worry yeah
i kept looking over my shoulder you know
and there'd be fish back there
following me yeah just wouldn't be a
shark what used to follow me was damn
sergeant major fish
and sheep's head look at the damn head
of a sheep
and i don't know what they were they're
just watching me to see what i'm doing
yeah some fish are like that it's like
when i used to um i used to go
snorkeling over at
uh some springs over there in central
florida
and you'd get like certain kinds of fish
are just like real curious
about people yeah they're like what are
what are you yeah it's kind of like
swimming around kind of looking at your
face and stuff like that did you get
food
which yeah i guess like in a place like
that there's a lot of divers yeah i mean
because you think in the wild they
wouldn't be following [ __ ] around
because it's like they think that maybe
it was a predator but i guess they know
it's not a predator
little sergeant major fish they're
probably about six inches in diameter
four to six inches in diameter like a
little discus type fish
yeah yeah they'll bite you yeah they
don't really break any skin okay but
they try to check
they won't go bumping hitting you and
you turn around and it's charging your
feet
what the [ __ ] to see if you take if
he could get a bite you know [ __ ]
they don't have any teeth like do you
taste good yeah their teeth are like
sandpaper you know they can't really
break your skin but then just check and
see if they can see
how soft you are yeah like no no food
nope okay no snacks for them to get
bitten by a fish a little bitty fish
yeah yeah it's happened to me too but uh
it's it's just funny the way they
they think they can get it they think
they can get a baby this big huge giant
person
but yeah so uh what was i gonna say oh i
was gonna say too that i had forgotten
too
not only had i forgotten how funny this
was i also forgot this has like some
kind of gory [ __ ] in it
like um you know they don't show a lot
like the
you know chrissy at the beginning the
one that gets the girl that gets eaten
they just kind of
suggest like you can kind of see your
hand and stuff but they have that one
scene where that dude's leg gets bitten
off and the leg which looks actually
really real
yeah floats down to the bottom and then
uh like i said mentioned earlier that
one of the best jump scares ever like
with that dude's [ __ ] head popping
out of the
hull of the boat with the big [ __ ]
hole in it yeah i looked at it again
it's not its head
it's the whole torch it's a whole torso
but yeah it's connected to the body
i think you know i always thought it was
just a head i did too isn't that that
way
in hd you see that no it's it's a whole
body just that
the head goes into the light yeah it
just pops out the hole
yeah and i think that's done really well
because i saw this other like uh
i i was watching a video that we're kind
of like analyzing how
you know the suspense was built up in
the movie and stuff and they said the
reason
why that was such a good jump scare is
that because up until this point in the
movie
they had established that when the shark
was around you heard the shark theme
yeah uh but this time you didn't hear
the shark theme because the shark wasn't
around
so they're kind of like putting the
audience at you know kind of uh
relaxing them because like oh you're not
hearing the music so the shark's not
there
and then pow this [ __ ] body comes
popping out of the hole
but yeah seriously um jaws 2 the sequel
was pretty good uh but skip all the
other ones
the third one the 3d one is awful but
it's actually pretty fun to watch
uh you know just for shits and giggles
if you're drunk or whatever
the fourth one had michael kane in it
and actually had the shark
stalking that particular family like
they moved to florida or something and
the same shark
or it wasn't the same shark obviously
because
maybe i gotta see that i saw it in the
theater that's how much of a sucker what
year was that
uh 87 i think the fourth one came out
what's it called jaws the revenge
of revenge and i think lorraine gary is
in it too who played brody's wife uh
in the first one but he you know he had
died subsequently like birdie's
character
and uh so she was a widow and so she
hooks up with michael caine
i think i haven't seen it a long time um
but it's
you would probably love it it's super
super cheesy
um the whole the whole thing the whole
premise of the movie
is that she and her family have moved to
florida because this
shark is apparently stalking them
because the shark is like super
intelligent
and the shark stalks them like all the
way to
florida and like targets them
specifically
they should have mixed that in with the
island
the pirates too the pirates and the
sharks
you guys have seen michael kane in the
island yeah we reviewed that one a while
back so uh yeah
there are pirates out there old pirates
they're still out there
yeah hide now david warner is a pirate
yeah
but yeah so now you gotta see jaws four
because you probably i i think you
probably like it
oh yeah i don't know it's not good but
it's yeah but it's
you know probably probably a music it is
actually
it's bad but it's it's fun bad you know
what i mean all right so
yeah if you haven't seen jaws um you
need to get on that like
right away because it's seriously we're
seeing it again
how could you not have seen jaws i
thought everybody in the world had seen
it
seen it again in [ __ ] hd blu-ray
[ __ ] great yeah
if you haven't seen it in a while
definitely you should check it out again
because
i like to watch it every few years you
know what i mean just stick together
real well it's classic man
it really did it still looks [ __ ]
great it still looks [ __ ] great yeah
but yeah so
that'll do it for this matinee we will
see you guys later
bye
you